let's bring in fox news senior political
analyst brit hume brett i you know i
hear this story and i just think
i've heard this before
boy have way ever i mean from the
beginning
epidemiologists and other leading
experts said
that young people particularly young
children
were very nearly invulnerable to this
disease and yet we closed down the
schools and colleges for the longest
time we closed down businesses
regardless of whether the people working
in those businesses were young or old
all of this in the name of trying to
prevent the spread of this disease and
yet look at how many people died from it
anyway there was a total failure all
along the line to look carefully at the
side effects of the measures that were
being taken to fight the disease and the
collateral damage was terrible i mean we
know about it in educational terms we
know about it in medical terms and
because people couldn't get appointments
that couldn't do regular health care
operations were postponed cancer streets
that weren't done the list goes on and
on and the damage is only now being
toted up i'm glad it is finally being
toted up and people at last beginning to
see
that we did the wrong thing there it is
amazing to see the stats being talked
about openly they were not for a very
long time the cdc acknowledging
where this was a public policy
miss in large part but also politically
here's president biden talking about at
that point florida governor ron desantis
and what he was doing
about covid in florida take a listen
i say to these governors please help
but you aren't going to help at least
get out of the way
use your power to save lives
now this was about kids and masks this
was about the danger to kids
there are people who say we didn't know
as much back then but there were a lot
of people who knew a lot about stats at
the beginning and yet it was a political
you know
weapon at times
it started out in some respects brett it
was the reaction to kobud was very much
along the lines of how people reacted to
donald trump if they didn't like trump
they were all for the measures to fight
covid and for bl and to blame him for
not doing more and to blame others like
governor desantis in florida who who who
regulated with a much lighter hand than
other governors did and ended up with no
worse results and he didn't shut down
the schools he didn't shut down his
state to nearly the extent that others
did and he came out in about the same
place or by some measures even better so
the covet alarmists in many respects
turned out to to have the wrong
prescription uh these these viruses do
spread
uh the phrase i heard again and again
during this period is virus gonovirus
and it did regardless of the measures we
took and those measures did uncalculable
damage and quickly britt um i'd be
remiss if i didn't ask you you're in
pennsylvania you've got this big primary
coming up tomorrow we had one of the
senate candidates obviously on the show
earlier
a big deal there in that state
yeah it is brett it's a very big deal
because of the worry among republicans
this season is that they have this
tremendous opportunity to regain control
not just of the house but also the
senate and the number of governorships
the governorship is up in this time
around and trump has come out with an
endorsement over the weekend that a lot
of that was done apparently without
consulting the republican leaders
they're not happy about the guy he
endorsed they think he's too far out
that he couldn't win in the fall and
they'll handle and hand the
the the state house uh governor's chair
back to the to the democrats to keep it
and on the senate side
he's inducted he's endorsed dr oz who
may well win
uh but the fear is that he can't be
elected elected in the fall and that the
trump heavy hand here will end up
hurting the party uh instead of instead
of bringing it to closer to victory and
the interesting thing about it is that
the agenda nearly all these republicans
have up here in both races is very
trumpy so you know you're going to get
the trump agenda no matter who you vote
for the question is whether they'll vote
for somebody who can actually win
all right brent as always thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else